from the daily wire republican arkansas
governor
asa hutchinson signed senate bill six on
tuesday that bans abortion unless the
life of the mother is endangered so this
is
almost a full-on abortion ban supporters
of the bill hope that it could force the
supreme court to revisit
roe v wade though opponents intend to
block it before the law takes effect
effect later this year um republican
state senator jason rapper
the bill's sponsor said we must abolish
abortion in this nation just as we
abolished slavery in the 19th century
all lives matter
hutchinson was at first reluctant to
sign the bill because it didn't provide
exceptions in the case of rape or incest
but explained in a statement
that he ultimately decided to support it
um
now a couple of things here first of all
there there
absolutely should not be exceptions for
rape rape and incest
when it comes to abortion bans um
there should be exceptions for the life
of the mother either
and the reason for that is very simple
that that's a non-existent category
so you might say it's no harm to put it
in there because that doesn't
that's not something that really exists
as in a life-saving abortion is not
something that exists
abortion has never saved the life of a
mother
there's never been a time when a woman
needed an abortion which is
an abortion what does that mean it means
to directly and intentionally kill
the child that's never been necessary to
save the life of of the mother
now there have been plenty of times when
um
you know especially we hear this
especially with with late late term
abortions
where we're told by the left that uh the
the only reason
why a woman would get a late-term
abortion is is you know
a catastrophic medical situation where
she needs it to save her own life
well yeah there may be cases where the
pregnancy has to
end in order to save the woman's life
the question is whether you kill the
child before you end the pregnancy
because one way or another especially
later term if you're ending the
pregnancy it means there's going to be a
delivery
it means you are taking the child out of
the mother's womb
right and absolutely if that needs to
happen to save the mother's life
do it the question is do you do you take
the extra step
of killing the child before you extract
him
from the womb or even as you are
extracting him from the womb which is
what they do in partial birth abortions
there's no way that you would need to do
that in order to save the mother's life
i mean there could be other cases really
difficult cases where a woman where
she's pregnant
uh you know is is diagnosed with
advanced stage cancer and she's told
that look if you treat the cancer
it might kill the child um but that's
not an abortion either
you know taking a step to treat an
illness
a disease or cancer in the mother
even if it were to have the effect
tragically of killing a child
that is not to directly and
intentionally kill a child so that's not
an abortion
so this is a made-up category the reason
i'm actually opposed to putting those
exceptions in
is that um the way that what the left
wants to do with the life of the mother
they want to expand that
to mean well not just life but physical
well-being
and by well-being we also mean emotional
well-being
and suddenly by the way that they
categorize it every abortion
in some sense preserves the life of the
mother because of nothing else that
preserves her
emotional well-being um
and for rape and incest you know the
reason why the exception shouldn't be in
there
to me again is is is simple which
doesn't make it easy
but it's simple just in the fact that
uh we do not punish children especially
with execution
for crimes committed by their father
that's that's not what what you do in a
civilized society
you want to talk about abortion
execution for rapists
we can talk about that i'm all ears
but you can't punish the child for that
that's why i think you don't make the
exceptions but uh in this case this is a
even with that exception in there this
is something to be
celebrated and will it will it cause
this confrontation
on the supreme court i don't know it
seems kind of far-fetched
it also seemed far-fetched that even if
it makes it to the supreme court
that this supreme court with its current
makeup
would vote to overturn roe v wade
gorsuch kavanaugh
you know roberts i don't see any of them
voting to overturn rugby way but even so
um it's uh it is certainly a major step
in the right direction well i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the matt wall
show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content